[Music]
carl is next in st louis hey carl what's
up
hey how are you doing dave so glad to
talk to you uh really excited again here
with you
um so my wife and i have kind of been in
debt most of her life and um boy i wish
i found you 20 years ago and we paid off
so much of our debt uh we paid off my
car a little quicker and after that we
started putting that car payment towards
her car then they got sick and tired of
her car and started putting extra from
savings to it and we kept our savings at
a set level and put the extra against
that car and i was talking to my
financial advisor about a week ago and
she's like oh my gosh she's got one more
month of this just paid off you're gonna
feel so glad you did and so i did i paid
off the car and bought it i feel excited
so the only debt we have remaining is
our house
and uh we owe forty five thousand
dollars in the house
um we have thirty five thousand in
savings um
and uh my financial advisor is like oh
man you should just just put 25 of that
against your house you can pay that off
in four months then and just be done
with it and then build your savings back
up
and so i was kind of like you know
should i leave more in savings should i
just follow that just just take a big 25
000 chunk against savings knock the
house out quick
or should i just
keep paying on the house more and knock
it out in about nine months good for you
wow
well i like your financial advisor
i thought you might i mentioned your
name to her so much of the time yeah
she hates debt she hates debt bad
and that's good because your
income once you get it all freed up is
she she knows the truth is going to
become your most
uh powerful
wealth building tool
when you're not giving it all to someone
else as a way of life and you're
beginning to experience the emotions of
these numbers in the last few months it
sounds like and it's very exciting for
you i'm proud of you yes super exciting
okay so we teach a process very that
comes from the same principles that
she's leaning on that's why she and i
like each other i can tell
and um so baby step one is save a
thousand dollars you've done that
okay baby step two has become debt-free
other than the home
and you've done that
baby step three
is have an emergency fund of three to
six months
of expenses
okay
okay so i don't want your savings below
three months of household expenses so if
your household expenses are three grand
a month
then we can go with her plan
well without a house payment it would
definitely be you have a house right
here you have a house payment still
yeah once that's knocked out
with house payment it's probably
okay with house payment monthly expenses
is probably
um well probably pretty close to three
okay well no that's not true i don't
think it's that much i'd say it's
probably i mean the house payment
household
um i make 145 my wife makes 48
right about forty eight she's not really
bad a couple couple of hundred a year
okay
and so um
uh
um
yeah
and if you take
you said there's 35 in there right in
your savings
yes and 40 on the high or 40 or 45 on
the house
35 in the house okay so if we throw 25
at it leave 10 in there like she
suggests
that means we have 20 left on a 200 000
household income
and you're done by christmas then
yeah i'll be down by christmas for sure
yeah
okay
i don't want you below 10.
because i are you okay with tim
um borderline but but
um
i just want you to gauge everything
around you and be very wary because if
you have a 15 000 event we got a problem
dude you make 200 grand and that's silly
yeah the other idea i had that i kind of
threw with my wife because um we were
putting what up you know the first thing
was
um take our house payment put our two
car payments against it and then put the
extra predict from savings which takes
us to a house payment of 5100 a month
we're just gonna keep cranking it up and
some other idea was every month you know
pay that and then pay an additional five
grand from savings and kind of see how
we feel as we're going with that that
would be okay too um
yeah i just don't want if i could
establish real comfortably what three
was i mean i'd be more comfortable with
15
i'd probably do it if it was 15.
but people often call me and say i have
enough money in my savings account to
pay off my house today and it would
leave me with one thousand dollars left
in my account
and i would tell them no and i i'm the
get out of debt guy
and i'm still telling them no because i
don't want you sitting there with one
thousand dollars at this stage of your
financial plan now at the beginning of
your financial plan when you're broke
and got a bunch of other debts and
everything else you're living on beans
and rice but this is more intentional
than it is intensity at your stage
and so i just want to be wise and
careful even though i'm as excited as
you are to get you out of debt so i'm
guessing that either way you're out of
debt by christmas
yeah it's going to be really close if
not i mean if we leave a little bit more
it's going to i think we're now i mean
another way you could another way you
could
you know another you know we'll just
keep manipulating the numbers here but
if you said okay let's just call it
three to six months let's call it 20
grand throw
uh the rest of it at it and then just
start chunking on the house you're still
gonna make it
and if you don't reach over and pull 10
out and take it down to 10 for one month
yeah in december but just go
december i'm done
as long as i don't go below 10 in my
savings but you could if the math works
the math works on throwing it at the
debt or it works and thrown into the
account then pulling out of the account
so either way is fine
and uh but i would not stop are you
saving for 401k i would not stop that
absolutely yeah my wife puts about 11
and i'm putting about seven percent in
yeah then i'm putting about another
eight percent into uh uh roth ira yeah
yeah you're getting you got the right
numbers and i wouldn't stop that either
so the the difference is only whether
it's uh christmas or whether it's march
that's the only difference and
and when you're 75 years old
that date won't matter i i like the
advice dave and i'd actually be a little
bit more cautious with that savings
because if if it's me and i really want
to get this because it's just intensity
he sees the finish line how could you
make 5 to 10 grand
extra that's what i'm looking at i i
like that savings posture i really do
having that just in case a big event
happens because you're talking about the
difference between three months
so it's great advice i certainly agree
with you i wouldn't personally i started
getting a little nervous listening to
that going lower and 15 myself
10 or 15 has got to be your floor yeah
for sure but i mean you could just throw
money you know leave the savings like it
sits
and throw money at the house and then
when you get within striking distance of
taking it down to 15 then do it in one
lick yeah then you're sitting on savings
the whole time while you're waiting to
do it
and um that won't mess you up either
you'll still get there in exactly the
same period of time
exactly
and so yeah it's a great place to be
though carl i love where your head's at
and i i like that you found a financial
advisor who's understood that getting
out of debt is the key to building
wealth
because not having any payments you know
what you can do if you don't have any
payments anything you want
i mean it opens up the door baby it's uh
americans live in such bondage that we
don't even know what it's like to be
free yeah i was getting ready to say if
you're new to the show and you're
listening and watching carl is a great
example of where you can be you know he
started off by saying i wish i had found
you 20 years ago but they've jumped into
the process and now he's looking at the
finish line he can't get there fast
enough it's a wonderful wonderful place